[Musique]
ces mouvements fluides c'est de l'aïkido
pendant une semaine un meeting
international est organisé par le club
de saint pierre les premiers
bénéficiaires
c'est eux
nous tous c'est chouette on peut
s'entraîner des fois on fait des jeux et
on apprend à se défendre au karaté le
judo il ya
il ya des adversaires énoncer des
partenaires donc c'est déjà mieux
au moins on n'attaque pas on se défend
juste parce que d'attaquer c'est méchant
je suis à koné de liquide effectivement
l'objectif c'est faire voir qu'il ya de
l'aïkido à la réunion ensuite l'associer
à un meeting international donc plus
orienté quand même un holster à dia
s'est aussi trouvé une cohabitation un
mélange avec avec le tous nos amis de
l'océan indien l'afrique du sud qui est
présent maurice qui est présent on n'a
qu'à cas de madagascar qui est présent
donc c'est déjà un premier élan qui
espère que ça va donner une belle chute
[Musique]
avec 300 licenciés sur huit clubs cette
discipline accompagné par le département
de la réunion est fondé sur d'autres
valeurs que celles de la compétition
l'harmonie le rapprochement des
pratiquants et le respect la saisie
c'est pas pour faire mal c'est pour
avoir des informations
groupe somebody to inform you when we
say hello
quand on se bourre jour le corps a
compris le futur on a et ils en ont
saisi comme ça qui saisit comme ça dans
la rue personne
donc ça marche pas dans la main paraît
que de foot cas les intérêts du foot
quel est l'intérêt du tennis on enrage
par une grenade avec une raquette pour
balancer dans l'intérêt c'est dé procès
de faire du sport
se confronter pour grandir en prenant
appui sur des valeurs avec un
développement océan indien et sous le
regard de son sens est loin d'un
phénomène de mode
cette discipline intergénérationnel
d'origine japonaise se promet un avenir
radieux